hi martin what are you doing
i'm trying to post a cat video to cat
tube
but there is a bug i filed an issue on
github yesterday but they haven't
responded yet
i wonder if there's a way to alert their
dev team when new issues are filed
sounds like a good job for web hooks
stay tuned if you'd like to know more
katie is a developer at cat tube she
wants to ensure that if someone files an
issue on github
her team is notified and the issue isn't
lost in her inbox
and honestly we try to read all emails
but those are just good intentions
luckily github is one of the many
services that provides event
driven web hooks what this means is that
if someone files an issue
github will send a request to a url
specified by the developer
katie can use cloudrun to host the new
webhook target
this means she won't have to worry about
servers and she can use the language and
framework she's comfortable with
the first thing katie has to worry about
is authorization
a webhook target is a public url and
anyone with the url
could send anything to it to ensure
she's only processing valid requests
katie uses a shared secret katie creates
a secret key and puts one copy in the
github configuration
and stores a copy securely with the
cloud secret manager
every request from github is signed so
katie uses the secret to validate the
signature and
only processes the valid requests
that's great but how does this help
alert her team
well now that she's able to securely
receive events from github
katie will use these events to send
messages to slack
katie already knows how to use the slack
api so she writes a function to send a
message to her team's slack channel
every time a valid request from github
is received
her team will never miss another issue
katie also wants the users to know that
her team is working
on the issue using the same web hook she
writes a function
to post an auto response back to the
github issue
finally she wants to measure how long it
takes her team to close an issue
she adds one more function to her web
hook to stream any issue events to
bigquery so she can easily create
metrics around her team's issue
performance
the full web hook target is now creating
notifications
triggering an action and streaming data
into bigquery
katie was happy to solve all three of
her issues using web hooks on cloud run
she gave me a one dollar bill how many
github issues would that process for her
cloud run pricing is based primarily on
the number of requests
and gigabyte seconds used each bug filed
in github will trigger
one request which will take cloudron
about one second
to process each request will stream a
row of data
into bigquery of about one kilobyte
katie will get two million cloud run
requests for free
but will be slightly over the free tier
on gigabyte usage
her total cloud run bill will be 78
cents
for streaming and storing the rows of
one kilobyte each
to bigquery katie will pay 13 cents
so that one dollar bill would let her
process 2 million bugs in a month
with a little change to spare that's a
lot of bugs
tune in next time to see how katie can
set up a more robust and fault
tolerant web hook using pubsub
[Music]
you